Stick around to the end of the video, where
we’ll look at all of the connections between
Mordeo and the Native American legend it’s
based on, The Wendigo.
This video is sponsored by CryptTV.
[Intro]
Welcome back to Things You Missed.
In this video, I’ll be breaking down everything
you missed in Offering, the new episode of
Mordeo on CryptTV.
For those who aren’t aware, Mordeo is a
serialization of the 2017 Crypt short film
of the same name, in which a cannibal in the
woods is transformed into a monster controlled
by the Mordeo.
We later find out in a Crypt announcement
video that the creature who appeared in that
short is merely a scout, a proxy of the Queen.
So the new episode opens, as many Crypt productions
do, with a little bit of gore.
This character Dan, gets his fingers chopped
off by a masked man simply known as The Butcher.
At first I assumed that the woman hiding out
behind the tree, Linda, was his girlfriend
or something.
However, Dan has a ring on his finger, and
she does not.
We’ll see if that actually ends up being
a significant part of the story or if it’s
just an extra detail.
The Butcher is carrying a book and a newspaper
with him and both contain important details.
He starts by referencing the book, which we
can quickly see based on the art style, is
the Crypt Tome, the book most prominently
featured in Sunny Family Cult. that contains
rituals men may use to turn themselves into
monsters.
The Butcher uses the book to find the ritual
site, and carry out the ritual.
He is able to get the Queen Mordeo to appear,
and seems to be excited to transform into
a monster, yelling out things like, “I’m
ready” and “please make me one of you.”
However, things don’t go as he expected.
The Queen bites off three of his fingers on
his right hand, the same fingers that he removed
from Dan at the beginning of the episode.
It is as it was told by the victim in the
original Mordeo short film.
“...there’s a price to pay for eating
flesh in these woods.”
So The Butcher is cursed with permanent finger
guns for life, which is really only another
minute or so because the Queen Mordeo snaps
his neck.
The butcher appears to have followed the ritual,
so why wasn’t he turned into a monster?
Let’s look back at the book.
It shows imagery of human flesh, along with
an open mouth and the words hunger, desperation
and offering.
There’s also an illustration of the hooded
scout from the original short film that this
series based on, so let’s look there for
more clues.
That one also has a cannibal eating flesh,
but in his case, he appears to be eating in
order to survive.
Listen to this dialogue.
“You were hungry.
There’s no shame in that.”
The Butcher in the new episode isn’t doing
it because he’s hungry, he’s doing it
to try to become a monster.
Hunger, desperation and offering.
These are the requirements that must be met
in order for the transformation to take place,
just as Roger had to meet certain requirements
in the third season of Sunny Family Cult.
That wraps up the mystery of The Butcher,
but we still don’t know why the other two
human characters, Dan and Linda, are out in
the woods as well.
When in doubt when watching Crypt TV stuff,
you always gotta look for paper.
Speaking of which, you should sign up for
the Crypt newsletter.
I mean, it doesn’t actually come on paper
it’s an email with updates on the Crypt
monster universe, special access merch drops
and insider info.
It’s free, just look for my link in the
description.
Anyway, the newspaper headline tells us what
we need to know going forward into this season.
There are three missing girl scouts, Angela,
Nancy and… uhh the other one.
Jen.
I told you.
Always look for papers.
This is just pure speculation, but Nancy looks
like she could possibly be related to Linda,
the girl we saw hiding from The Butcher.
My guess is that Linda and Dan are out searching
for the missing girls.
The name of the newspaper is The Mohawk Ledger,
which ties into another Crypt series, Mohawk,
which takes place in a tiny New York town
in a modern setting.
However, Mordeo takes place about 40 years
before that.
If you pause on the newspaper right before
the blood hits it, you can see the date, October
29th 1979.
That also places this just two days before
Halloween, which may or may not be significant
once we get into those later episodes.
In addition to the search for those missing
girls, there’s also another clue pointing
towards a possible crossover with another
Crypt TV franchise.
This symbol carved on the fallen tree doesn’t
match up with the symbol of Mordeo, but rather,
the icon of The Birch, another forest dwelling
monster and a protector of good children against
evil.
The inclusion of the Birch symbol could be
just a small promotion for The Birch, which
is getting a series of its own this year,
but it could also mean that The Birch is in
the same territory as Mordeo, and may appear
to the aid of the missing girls if Mordeo
comes hunting.
If that happens, expect to see a huge showdown
between Mordeo and The Birch.
Mordeo is based off of a mythological creature
known as The Wendigo.
The Wendigo is an Algonquian legend associated
with famine, greed and cannibalism.
This episode reflects those themes by introducing
The Butcher, a product of greed who is willing
to resort to cannibalism not to survive, but
simply to gain more power.
The Wendigo is a demonic creature with a humanoid
form and the head of a stag.
It’s hunger can never be satisfied, so it’s
always looking for new victims, making it
a metaphorical tale the Algonquian people
would tell their young to discourage greedy
behaviour.
It roams forests in the Northern Atlantic
Coast in North America, which is likely why
the territory of Mordeo resides in Mohawk,
New York.
Tribal members would sometimes perform a ceremony
during times of famine in order to discourage
taboo behaviours.
The ceremony involved dancing around a drum
while wearing horned masks, which may have
something to do with the mask worn by The
Butcher in this episode.
Some legends say that The Wendigo has an effect
on the entire region that it inhabits, causing
evil spirits to possess locals.
There are many different versions of the legend.
The only way to find out what creepy twists
Crypt TV puts on this native folktale is to
subscribe to their channel and catch new episodes
of Mordeo and other Crypt Monster Universe
videos every Friday.
Don’t forget to sign up to that newsletter
to stay up to date on even more great content
and as always, I’ll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.